[Music]
how would the playing fields be leveled
if there was a pill that could give any
ordinary person extraordinary power
you're about to witness a very rare
power
thermoregulation this one can get a bit
intense
that's one of the questions posed by
netflix's new original sci-fi action
blockbuster project power
as it turns out the answer is anything
but simple
at the beginning of the movie we're
introduced to robin played by dominique
fishbach in a star making performance
robin is a young drug dealer raising
money for her sick mother's medical
expenses she's peddling an intense
substance recently introduced to the
streets of new orleans referred to as
power
which imbues the user with a specific
superhuman ability for five minutes
the catch is that everyone's power is
different so if yours ends up being
spontaneous
combustion your first dose of power will
be your last
one of robin's clients is frank a
well-intentioned new orleans police
officer played by joseph gordon-levitt
who wants to use the pill to establish
equality between the police
and the super-powered criminals who are
wreaking havoc in his city
did you take a pill today
yes over the course of one night robin
and frank become embroiled in a shadowy
conspiracy when robin is kidnapped by
jamie foxx's art
a military veteran desperate to find the
people behind power who have taken his
daughter tracy
the last act of project power begins
after we see art disrupt a demonstration
of power held by telios
the military defense contractor
developing the pill he's finally
apprehended by frank who's been trying
to track him down after his captain
played by courtney b vance
tells him that art is heavily involved
in the distribution of power
however once they're in the car together
art tells frank that the captain who's
clearly in league with telios in some
way is setting him up
frank is extremely skeptical of art a
few minutes earlier frank told robin not
to trust
art because he's just using her to
achieve his own goals but as robin
points out to frank that's hardly unique
to just art
come on frank we gotta help him you
already did help him you brought him
here you're not paying attention he's
using you
what and you don't at least he's being
honest about it
when ateliers van shows up to intercept
frank and art on their way to the police
station frank realizes that there was
wisdom in robin's statement
even though art has his own agenda he's
never been dishonest about it and he is
indeed telling the truth about frank's
captain having ulterior motives
frank's captain betraying him is an
example of one of the main themes in
project power one which art explains the
robin halfway through the movie because
in the real world the power goes to
where it always goes to the people
that already have it in this instance
the leaders of the nopd are the people
who already have power
and they're working to keep it frank
believes in his personal mission to keep
the people of new orleans safe but he
realizes the people at the top of the
system he works within don't share that
goal and likely never will
art allows himself to be taken into
custody because he knows it will get him
closer to the person at the top of the
operation
this person is gardner played by amy
landecker thanks to a flashback we know
gardner experimented on art when he was
an early test subject for project power
she's also the one who organized the
kidnapping of tracy because she was born
after telios experimented on art tracy
has the abilities of power without
actually having to take a pill
when art is brought to gardner on the
dock ship she's operating out of gardner
explains her justification for
kidnapping his daughter
she uses the example of henrietta lacks
a real-life black woman who had cancer
cells harvested from her body in the
1950s without her consent or knowledge
with the cells later being used in a
number of important scientific
breakthroughs
in gardner's world view the ends justify
the means all of our greatest
advancements
began in darkness major it's up to the
pioneers to light the way
the gardener uses lacks in her
explanation for her motives is an
important key to unlocking the major
themes of project power
in the united states there's a long and
terrifying history of unethical medical
experimentation on black people and
other minority communities
such as the tuskegee study in the world
of project power telios is continuing
that history by experimenting on art's
daughter
tracy and using new orleans a majority
black city as one of its testing grounds
for the pill
gartner justifies this by repeating the
teleos line that power represents the
next step in human evolution
but who's set to reap the rewards of
that evolution as art pointed out
earlier the power will remain in the
hands of people like gardner
now that art has been captured he's
restrained in the hull of the ship
earlier we learned from atelio's
representative that the powers people
get from the pill are inspired by
adaptations found within the animal
kingdom such as that of a chameleon
we also heard from art that he's only
ever used his power once because it was
so intense that it almost killed him now
that he's tied up bart explains to the
guard who's assigned to watch over him
that his powers are those of the pistol
shrimp
while the pistol shrimp is small it's
able to shoot a jet of bubbles with such
force that produces a flash of extreme
heat and sound destroying everything in
its path
little bitty guy look harmless but hit
you so fast
it vaporizes the water around art
manages to escape the guard without
using his power with the help of robin
and frank who have infiltrated the ship
robin locates tracy and breaks her out
of the cell she's been kept in they
reunite with art and frank but the
foursome is eventually surrounded by
gardner's henchmen
with no other way out dart takes a power
pill and lays waste to the teleo's
soldiers
art's power is immensely destructive and
so difficult to control that it ends up
killing him however he's not dead for
long as tracy is able to revive him
using her own innate
abilities art's particular power is rich
with metaphor
as a single person struggling against
the giant system he's functionally as
small as the pistol shrimp but he's also
just as mighty when he needs to be
earlier in the film we learned that
despite the fact that she sells power
pills robin hasn't actually taken one
herself
because she thinks they are too
dangerous out of the three lead
characters robin is the only one who
doesn't come from a law enforcement
background like frank or military
background like art
in fact robin is someone who exists
almost completely outside of any kind of
formal power structure
she's flunking out of school her job is
entirely off the books and her life
stream is to become a rapper
a goal that relies on her own skills and
hard work to achieve
frank and art have been enmeshed in the
exact power struggles that we see being
corrupted by the power pills but robin
hasn't
furthermore while both frank and art use
power to achieve their goals robin
refuses because she doesn't believe the
risk is worth the reward
after they've escaped from the ship art
thanks robin for helping him reunite
with tracy and gives her a line of
advice
there's something great inside you robin
use it here the film seems to be drawing
a clear distinction between a power
that's acquired from an outside source
and the power that comes from within
yes the pills give art extreme abilities
but they're so strong that he can't use
them without killing himself in the
process
similarly frank uses power to fight back
against criminals but every pill he buys
is profiting telios and only leading to
more chaos
robin on the other hand doesn't need to
corrupt herself to use her innate powers
of perseverance compassion
strength and street smarts in the end
project power reaches a relatively happy
conclusion
you think you could heal a gunshot wound
all four of our heroes managed to escape
the ship and make it to dry land
frank reveals that he's going to leak to
a journalist he knows about telios and
the corruption within the police
department
meanwhile art and tracy write off to
begin a new life while robin reunites
with her mother and reveals she has the
money to pay for her operation of course
at the end of any big summer blockbuster
there's an inevitable question
will there be a sequel project power
doesn't explicitly set up a sequel but
it certainly lays some groundwork for
one
when we learn a bit more about telios we
find that the pill itself is actually
just an early prototype and that part of
the reason they're testing it out on the
citizens of new orleans is so they can
develop another more stable version
and although gardner and her ship are
destroyed at the end of the movie it's
clear that the forces behind power are
much larger than one operation
before he leaves frank asks art one
final question and he gets a telling
answer
you think this is really over
for me it is there seems to be an
implication that the story of power
project is in fact
just the beginning of a much bigger
fight check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies and tv shows
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one